one of the interesting things i guess
about me was i wasn't absolutely sure i
wanted to do computer science until i
did it for the first time i always had
an interest in programming i'd done a
bit of programming not a lot not a lot
of programming but a bit of programming
before i came to university
but once i started university i really
really enjoyed it i love the programming
i love learning about cool new data
structures that just for some reason
made the same job way easier than it was
before
and you know um and loads of cool stuff
like computer vision
and you know graphics computer graphics
and writing games and things
and you know i was kind of hooked after
that and then i started you know
programming in my own time at home for
fun
question from me rather than the viewers
then where were you where would you have
gone if you didn't
well yeah i i considered a i considered
a degree in physics i considered a
degree in biology because
i found i find life sciences and stuff
really interesting i absolutely no idea
i think probably biology because i think
you know the natural world is kind of
cool
but um but heck i've sort of found found
my way intolerantly interface you know i
do lots of plant
plant imaging and stuff like that so
i've kind of got both now
we have asked for a few questions from
some of our viewers and
uh i'm gonna pose them to you if that's
all right sure yeah okay
so the first one is how did you
specialize how did you
get into doing what you do so maybe we
need a little line on what it is that
you do first
yes i study computer vision so that is
taking pictures and trying to get
computers to understand pictures kind of
like we do
now my specific area is kind of more
applied computer vision to do with sort
of plant phenotyping medical imaging
these kind of things
um so how i got into this i guess
i guess it goes all the way back to
towards the end of my degree and i was
deciding whether i wanted to stay in
academia
or i wanted to leave academia and go
into industry which of course is
kind of the two choices i was posing
myself i was always going to stay in
computer science because i really enjoy
you know programming and things but i i
sort of i asked around to try and work
out what it was like to a phd
and also but also it was quite important
to me what was the impact of doing a phd
on my possible career in industry
if i decided not to take it any further
than that you know could i do a phd
and then get the benefits of that and
then actually just go into industry
anyway
and the answer was yes you're not going
to get three years of industry
experience and move up the ranks but
you're not going to get worse off
you know i think and i think that some
places really respect a phd so that's
always good as well um
so i just kind of started doing one you
know and i enjoyed computer vision when
i did it as undergraduate projects and i
did it you know
in the lectures and the courseworks that
we did as an undergraduate and so i
ended up just
sticking with that and you know here i
am i didn't leave after my phd that's
the thing and i'm still here
somebody's asked why would you want to
do a phd
yeah i that was the same question i
asked myself a phd is not
necessarily what everyone thinks it is
in in the very simplest terms a phd is a
long long project a bit like you would
do sort of for an undergraduate
dissertation
but it's much more focused it's much
more in detail because you've got that
much more time
and obviously the level is going to be a
bit more advanced
i think that if you enjoyed the project
and the research parts
of your uh undergraduate degree then a
phd would suit you quite well
right if you just like to practical
stuff hands-on building something
then you will do some of those things in
a phd but you know it's a bit more
research oriented
obviously if you want to go into
academia then a phd is going to be
at this first step in that process but
even if you
just want to go into industry a phd will
give you some specific skills like the
ability to learn
the ability to write well-presented
documents and sometimes also to give
good oral presentations as well
you know because you do a lot of those
things during the time so you know
you'll learn lots of really great skills
and of course you know if you're doing a
phd in computer vision or deep learning
or something you'll learn a lot about
that specific area
which will make you a world expert in
that area which you know might be useful
for
whatever you want to do next that brings
on to the next question so with all that
learning and academia
how do you learn about different topics
somebody's asked
it's a good question actually because
i'm not absolutely sure i think that
it's practice
for me i think that when you're an
undergraduate
it takes sometimes quite a long time to
learn different topics and so you could
have to work do quite a lot
of revision for a given exam or
something like that to really make sure
that you know it
um one i think a phd there's a lot of
self-directed learning you've got to
read a lot of papers you've got to take
on a lot of knowledge
very very quickly and i think you do get
better at it um
and so now i can read you know papers or
you know wikipedia articles or news
articles and pretty quickly work out
what's going on
and i think it's just practice and
experience um so keep at it i think
and it's a useful thing to have and it's
something a phd will give you
um because then you can you know do lots
and lots of different computer files
having learned lots and lots of
different things
i know that you do quite a bit of deep
learning stuff in your work somebody has
asked how
the architectures for these you know
googlenet leonard
alexnet how are they designed how do
they come up with those
it's a very good question i think so but
general the general way most people
hear about these because they get
released in publications and so
obviously the question is about
how do the original authors of those
publications come up with some new
architect if it does something a little
bit different
to what happened before that maybe
performs a little bit better
i think there's a lot of different
things sometimes it's intuition and you
know you're an expert in something
and you know that it works a certain way
but if you change it this way maybe
you'll see an
improvement and it won't always work but
sometimes you will see that improvement
alex net and leonet they're sort of
early examples of deep networks so they
were kind of pioneering
but in some sense also quite simple
architectures because that's what we had
back then
um more you know more recently you know
things like that then is what in
10 years ago well you know not even that
sort of 20 2012 to 2014 kind of time so
so really actually this is all very very
recent so
you see a lot of new architectures
because of this because
people are still coming up with new
ideas so maybe you've got some
you've got some data that you're trying
to perform really really well on
and you test it on some of these example
algorithms and architectures that you've
already seen
and it works in some ways and not in
other ways and so you have to try and
instinctively think what is it that i
could change about this
that would lead it to perform better in
these circumstances right
and then if you want to get a
publication on this then what you have
to do is
explain why it's better you know not
only has it improved it but also why so
that people can get some insight
and maybe use those techniques
themselves so it's kind of it's kind of
trial and error a bit of intuition
and you know it's a bit like normal
science you're basically throwing things
into a test tube and seeing what comes
out i guess
but the test tube is is a deep network
somebody's asked
what do you think of formal methods
formal methods i don't have a problem
with formal methods
i think people like torsten do an
excellent job on formal methods and i
steer well clear
i think they you know they're very
important in certain circumstances
um but you know i don't tend to use them
very often do you have any book
recommendations for cryptography
yeah so i always recommend ross
anderson's book whilst anderson's been
on computer file a few times
and his book's really really good he's
currently writing as far as i know a new
version
some of which might be available online
if you want to check it out if it is
i'll
we'll put a link in um but you know
when it actually is released you should
definitely get that book because it has
a whole
you know whole lot of information on
cryptography but also other parts of
security
engineering which are really really
important if you want a more detailed
look at
cryptography specifically and sort of
skipping over some of the other aspects
of computer security
then something like cryptography
engineering by niels ferguson and others
another option if you're interested in
going sort of from the basics to some
quite advanced cryptographies um
is introduction to photography by
christoph parr also he's
his lectures are online on youtube so
you should check them out as well
there's a question here
about uh how people in industry can keep
up to date with what research has gone
into academia
so some industries they're very clued up
to what's going on in academia
particularly those working in ai because
you have to be
everything moves really really fast and
actually a lot of industries producing
papers and putting them into the major
vision conferences for example
so so as an example suppose you wanted
to be
you know you work in industry and you
wanted to be kept abreast of what the
latest ai
research is going to is going on then
you'd want to be keeping an eye on you
know things like eurips and cvpr
and other big conferences where some of
these big hitting papers are going to
appear right and
i mean one of the downsides is they can
produce they can publish thousands of
papers and so you've got to be able to
be quite selective in what you read
because you just couldn't possibly read
them all
so you've got to look for subjects
you're interested in
and i think this is also true of most
areas so computer security has
conferences and
and um and journals and so on that are
going to release some of these uh
new attacks and new uh explorations of
security
and the this is a place where you would
read about these things um so you just
have to do a bit of reading around
get used to reading the abstract to work
out if you want to read the introduction
to work out if you want to read the
results you know this kind of
kind of filtering system but this does
work both ways you know from academic
from an academic point of view
one thing i've noticed is that we tend
to we tend to be a little bit haphazard
sometimes with our software development
right because it when you're doing
research code you're coding very very
quickly and one experiment doesn't work
one minute and you've changed to another
experiment and you just no don't worry
about that
some of the things that you have to have
done like proper testing and things like
that
we you know we don't tend to worry about
that too much in research right we will
test we will validate our approach you
know on the data
but in terms of robust robustness you
know for security for example
i don't worry about that in my deep
learning models because it's not
important to my research
but if you were going to build that into
a system that would be more important so
some knowledge of how you would might go
about doing that is going to help
if you want to get industry using your
academic work
or you want other researchers to take it
and run with it you know
if your code is really really difficult
to use it doesn't matter how good your
paper is right
people are going to it's going to slow
up take so actually i think some good
industry best practice is going to help
you know especially when you release
your code
alongside a publication so in your
specialist area image processing what
what tools do you use
my work is kind of applied so i'm
interested in like the whole pipeline
from you know image capture all the way
to uh
some decision or something you know some
some meaningful information and so
if for image capture you're either going
to use proprietary drivers from the
manufacturer
or i might use something like opencv
which has a lot of drivers for you know
and and can do most simple camera
capture pretty easily
and has a lot of it's a library that has
a lot of
image processing routines to do simple
you know you know
thresholding and segmentation and edge
detection and things like this right so
you can get things done quite quickly
um a lot of what i do now is python
centric
and so opencv works in python um
and that also is where we do our deep
learning as well i use pytorch
but and a lot of our lab uses pi torch i
think mostly just because
it's helpful for us to use mostly the
same thing because that way we can work
together on stuff but actually
you know there are lots of labs using
tensorflow and it's it's fine you know
um i think you just pick one and
run with it um if you know one you know
most of them you know
in the way they work so yeah that would
be where i get started and then you know
things like um
scipy and things like these are gonna
have lots and lots of algorithms for
doing
some of the other machine learning and
stuff that you might want to do as well
what's your favorite cipher
we did the video on the fiesta cipher
right i think that's amazing the first
cipher on its own i guess is not an
actual algorithm
i suppose if i had to pick one then i'd
pick probably aes because i think it's
impressive how
widely used it is and it didn't come
from a huge lab
you know with huge resources or a huge
company like ibm so i think that's
pretty cool but the first life is the
best
potential controversy where do we draw
the line between
national security and privacy
how long do we have um that's a really
good question
i think that i'm more relaxed about this
than some and less relaxed than others
so you know most of my family don't
worry about this kind of stuff at all
you know they'll install any app
no matter how many money permissions it
asks for um
i won't but on the other hand i
understand that maybe governments have a
role to play in preventing certain
things from happening
and you know i'm kind of okay with that
to an extent as well
so i think the balance we're striking at
the moment
is not terrible i think that you know we
have some encrypted apps that they
they're not reading um but if you're
doing something really bad
they have ways you know to be able to
work that out and prosecute you for that
right and i think that's probably a
position i'm okay with
um but i don't think it's an easy
question i think that you know
sometimes governments overtread and
sometimes they didn't have enough
resources and something happened that
shouldn't have happened you know
um so i don't have all the answers
um yeah but that's kind of my opinion it
sort of links nicely into a question
someone's asked about encryption and
whether it has backdoors and whether
we can trust things like signal yeah so
i think you can
trust signal not just because it's open
source but i think that
it's unlikely that signal's been been
compromised and i think that's probably
the prevailing opinion
of most security researchers
i think that from a business point of
view
let's suppose you're running you know a
big instant messenger
um it's it's better for you not to have
government back doors because they are
only ever going to be pr nightmares for
you
right um it's easier from a sort of
legal point of view when someone does
something bad on your platform if you
can say i couldn't possibly have read it
right so actually from a business point
of view i think they benefit from this
end-to-end encryption
i do think that governments will quite
like backdoors in some of these things
and probably ask uh but you know whether
or not they're granted i i doubt
in most cases but i don't know but there
was a suspicion of things like elliptic
curve
yeah yeah we did a video on that and it
probably was true and then there was log
logjam as well i don't know
did we do a video on logjam if we didn't
i'll do a video on logjam
um very cool but yeah there are there
are
attacks from government agencies on you
know standard
uh encryption and things like this
because through that they can better
perform their job right now sometimes
people will think they overreach right
that's the the previous question i was
talking about
i think in general most attacks are done
on end devices and not on the actual
lines of communication between the two i
think if you wanted to hack someone if
you thought someone was doing something
they shouldn't have been doing on signal
it would be easier for you to hack their
device or hack the device at the other
end but it would be for you to break
into signal itself
and i think that's probably what they
would do so again i'm going to link
these two questions together because
they feel like they're sort of polar
opposites but what is the
first project they're really proud of
and conversely what's the worst
piece of code you've ever written yeah i
mean it's important to note here that i
write plenty of bad code
right so does everyone no one is immune
to this um
i i did once write a piece of code that
i found later
um i actually i tweeted about it at a
time where it just said to do
schema validation and i just left it
blank so it didn't do anything
i'm sure it was fine uh it probably
worked so you know that was that was the
research with me going
that's something to do sort of
professionally later to make it tidy
but right now my research code is
working i'll just just not worry about
it you don't get jobs
uh in industry for acting like that
i guess the proudest thing so i've done
lots of things during my academic career
that i'm pleased with from a software
uh point of view um when i was doing my
phd
i wrote an implementation of the early
stock
probabilistic parser which i was really
pleased with so dave's done a lot of
videos on grammars
a probabilistic context free grammar is
one that has probabilities attached to
different branches
and so there's quite a lot of
computation to do with what the
likelihood is of certain
you know ambiguous things happening and
this was useful for part of my research
let's let's not go into it but i had to
implement this and it took me a good
month
or you know each day um because i was
working on my own i wasn't familiar with
with the literature um
but by the end you know i was really
pleased with myself
now i don't know how long it would take
me now hopefully a little bit shorter
right i've learned some things but i
don't know it was i didn't
find it easy right so i was really
pleased with that so how would you get
started on a
career in data science or machine
learning i mean there's a few different
ways
a master's isn't going to hurt
especially if that's the kind of thing
that the jobs you're applying for
are asking for but to begin with i think
you need to start trying to learn about
there are lots of online courses on this
kind of stuff and you need to try and
learn
about the standard methods for you know
traditional machine learning
feature representations dimensionality
reduction cleaning data all these kind
of standard techniques that you're going
to need to learn about
and become very very familiar with them
by running through tour examples and
doing this over and over again
i think again it's practice you've got
it you've got to practice these things a
bit like practicing other kinds of
aspects
of programming so that you can do them
quite quickly and i think if you can
demonstrate those things
you're going to be a strong candidate
for a job in this area do you think that
it's a good idea to variety specialists
to pursue
certification and to follow standards
standards yes i think standards are very
important um you know i'm not coming at
this from industry bear in mind so you
know
uh i'm an academic with a view into
industry
who's sort of making the best effort he
can um i think that standards are very
very important and
good knowledge of standards is very very
important in fact comes with a
certificate i don't think that's a bad
thing
i wouldn't seek out certificates for
certificate at stake in the sense that
unless your job requires it i don't
think that having some label
is necessarily going to help if you can
already do that you know when i'm
hiring people for an academic position
i'm really interested in what it is they
can do
rather than you know how many different
things they've got down on paper
you know so um if you can demonstrate
that you can do something that's gonna
it's gonna be really useful to me you
know even if it doesn't come with a
certificate somebody's asked do you
think that
encryption can always outpace decryption
is that right
yes probably i mean famous last words um
at the moment we have encryption that
operates in fractions of a second
but would take you know trillions of
years to decrypt so
at the moment very much that's very much
the case obviously i can't account for a
new
weird type of computer that might appear
but i i think so
yeah i think that jumbling things up is
easier than unjumbling them a bit like
mixing paint right we you know we talk
about this in different helmet and stuff
there are some problems but are much
easier in one direction than the other
and while they still exist i think we'll
always have a good place here
so i'm quite optimistic actually about
about things like this i think that
people's security is getting better
overall
you know we see breaches and leaks and
stuff all the time and it's very
important that we deal with these but
you know 20 years ago nothing on the
internet was encrypted at all
you know and all your passwords were out
in plain text every day
and we didn't bother zen we were fine um
but it's much better now so i think we
are definitely moving in the right
direction
what's the best website to go to for
computer security research
okay youtube.com computer file i
i'm not absolutely sure there's a few um
my i guess if you had to pick one apart
from obviously reading through wikipedia
you know which actually
sometimes is is people complaining that
wikipedia you know it's difficult to
source it and things but actually a lot
of their security articles are very good
so
you know read those so the open web
application security project or o-wasp
or o-wasp
i don't know it seems to be a a kind of
like a wikipedia for security right and
i found that really useful and it has
very detailed articles so that's a
really good place to go
and also you can follow the um blogs of
big
you know security researchers like ross
anderson bruce schneier and so on
um and they'll be highlighting you know
new papers new developments and
interesting things in the news that have
happened so that's worth a read as well
we want to do is move these things
around and permute them so
if this is our data path with our
columns by sharing bytes around the
different columns
when we combine it with the mixed column
step which we'll do in a minute
you'll see that actually we're mixing
everything up and it does kind of make
green
this is a bit orangey let's not critique
me too much so yeah